وفي المقابل قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه مع رياض خاروفه ان روسيا
تحتفظ بحق اتخاذ اجراءات رد صارمه على ما
وصفتها بالهجمات الارهابيه الاوكرانيه على
القرم وموسكو واضافت ان روسيا متاكده من
وجود دعم امريكيين بريطاني للهجمات
الاوكرانيه التي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه في
روسيا
بدا يستخدم على ارض المعركه القنابل
العنقوديه التي زودته بها الولايه المتحده
هذه القنابل استهدفت سياره الصحفيين روس
حيث قتل مراسل عسكري واوصيب اخرون بجروح
وعلى الرغم من تحذير المجتمع الدولي
ورؤساء عشرات الدول والمنظمات الدوليه
المعنيه من تزويدك بالقنابل العنقوديه ما
يعد خرقا للمعايير الانسانيه اقدمت
الولايات المتحده على ذلك ولن يرضعها الا
رد قاسي وملائم هجمته اوكرانيا التي
تستهدف البناء التحتيه الروسيه مدعومه من
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والحديث عن
السلام يبدا بوقف ضخ الاسلحه في اوكرانيا